first of all most sex toy things are
just kitchen items just let's get that
straight what else can this be really if
there's a disco situation here
like it's like got two little disco
balls and they turns it vibrate or
anything no it kind of looks like a
dolphin with balls I think I want to say
sex toy toy
this is totally a doctor there's
something inside of the ball that's
jiggling around this well like if I'm
stressed out I feel like I could just
shake this up my desk I'm gonna say it's
not a sex toy but I'm not sure what this
is for pizza is this what you used to
make ravioli it's just a lot of pain I
feel like it's just like making pasta
maybe I got pasta cutter I'd be really
shook if this was used as a sex
toy
[Music]
so we've got a very long metallic object
good sturdy implement the bottom has
like a texture to it you get that stab a
stick if you just go you just go at it I
feel like you could use this for like
muddled herbs for drinks right
[Music]
it kind of feels like a balloon it's
reverie no it's not a bracelet it's too
small you could probably use this as a
hair tie these are very tricky you can
seal some chips I don't know
this is definitely a sex toy
[Music]
this is glass which means this is
definitely not for a dog
I know cows like rock candy covered in a
little niggly knobblies I personally
would use this as a paperweight
I feels like a massage like a pressure
pointed thing I still don't think this
is a sex toy
[Music]
super easy to grip yeah it's not flimsy
it's not gonna break this is really
really really spiky this looks like what
you would use to hold corn this is
definitely not a sex toy
[Music]
what is this what is this not a sexy
green color this feels like part of a
vacuum this looks like it fell off of
something else does this go on a hose
not affect all it's heavier than I
thought it would be I don't I can't tell
if this is like a metal band I would
think you would you know play catch with
this maybe it's probably a sex toy
rub away its metal it's pretty hard I
don't know if this it looks like a bar
of soap I feel like this one is like a
trick object I feel like this is a soap
holder I don't think this is a sex slave
[Music]
Valente it looks like a luxury product
there's the top thumb up it's vibrating
what's that yeah I know what that is
well this thing really only be one thing
oh yeah this is a sex toy I feel a
little grandma ish right now cuz I
missed a lot of those I'm just really
upset I don't know how to feel we're
creative people both in and out of the
bedroom I'll spy about everything with
the dildo which is like of course I
would
[Music]
you